is the first committee session where
we've welcomed our new members and for
public benefit their register of
interests is out there in the public
domain and if any of them are relevant
to the questions that they're going to
be asking you they will declare those
interests at that time
right well you've had an unpredictable
summer I think it's fair to say Richard
and you had presumably
thought that you might be invited to
prepare your economic Outlook
over the summer give me I mean from your
personal point of view how was that
expressed to you what when were you
first told that your services were not
going to be required
yes it has been an unusual process
um leading up to to this moment
um when the when the leadership election
for for leadership of the conservative
party
um and and section the new prime
minister was initiated we approached the
treasury and had a discussion about our
expectation that a new prime minister
and a new Chancellor would need an
updated forecast from us to make
whatever fiscal decisions they wanted to
make
um we made that approach in Late July
and and by mutual agreement with the
treasury set in train the process for
preparing an updated forecast we thought
that was particularly important because
there'd been some big movements in
forecast determinants since our last
forecast back in March in particular gas
prices had started rising and then kept
Rising through the suburb
um interest rates also started to rise
over the course of the summer and then
again through momentum picked up through
August so you worked on it throughout
the summer we did although we our
initial deadline was to make sure that
it was ready for the new Chancellor to
be on his desk
um at the time of his appointment
um in the early September and and and by
by the time quasi classing arrived in
the treasury in early September he had a
uh an updated forecast from us on his
desk so it reached his desk and then
when were you told that it wasn't going
to be published so we were reformed
shortly after that the precise status in
the forward to the document but my
recollection was it was at the end of
that week
um we were informed that he was he did
not he would not go to request to
forecast from us to accompany any fiscal
statements he was going to make later on
in the month and what you have published
now is obviously quite a bit shorter
than what you have typically done what
have you left out
um so it is shorter than our usual
forecast it's it's just over 60 Pages
whereas at our typical info is well over
200.
um there are some people who've liked
the new shorter format it's more concise
more readable I think there are others
um and Anthony's nodding his head um uh
but there are others who who have missed
some things um the reason it was shorter
was that we were in essence uh having to
maintain a constant state of Readiness
to publish a forecast we had three
different deadlines throughout the
process two two of which were moved
forward
um so we had to be prepared to a keep
iterating on the forecast and publish it
relatively short notice that meant that
our time to write it up was more limited
um it is a shorter document we've made
sure we satisfied all the legal
requirements of an Etho set out by
parliament in legislation it has meant
that we've gone into less detail on
aspects of the forecast than we usually
would in particular that's not what
there's not the long Annex on policy
measures that you would usually see in
IFA we've had to keep that shorter and
more summery
um there's fewer boxes uh this time
around we only had four boxes going sort
of in depth into into analysis uh
ordinarily we'd have sort of over 10
sometimes in amifo going into different
issues so there's less that we haven't
had as much of a chance to explain our
logic around key analytical questions
nor explore some of the policies in
depth and I should really emphasize
um this is not necessarily The New
Normal we really want to get feedback
from yourselves in particular but also
other users of our documents about
whether they welcome a more concise
product or whether they miss all the
content that they used to have before
I mean I think this can be
commit over the summer
asking for your forecast to be published
alongside what has been referred to
obviously as a mini budget but obviously
was quite major in terms of some of the
measures in it in in September and as I
understand it you mentioned the legal
situation you're required to publish one
of your forecasts alongside a budget and
that's why these euphemistic terms of
mini budget and fiscal event have
entered our language to prevent you from
actually publishing your documents
alongside it so do you think we in this
committee and in Parliament should be
changing some of the legal language to
make sure that you know major changes to
tax and spend in this country are
accompanied by one of your forecasts
um I think it is a good principle of
fiscal policy making that major physical
decisions should be should be based upon
and presented alongside a latest and
up-to-date view of the economic account
and did your lawyers advise that it's
the word budget
that is the key thing they did and the
law says that we have to produce two we
have to publish two forecasts a year and
one of them has to accompany the budget
but the law also says that it is for the
chancellor to decide when our forecasts
are published and it was for that reason
that despite the fact that we had
forecasters ready at the time because
the chancellor did not ask us to publish
them they remain confidential advice uh
to minister
thank you and um in terms of the
forecasts themselves and we all accept
that you know no forecast is ever going
to be perfect a prediction of what
happens in the future and
um what you're looking at at really are
the risks around uh the the the the
prediction that you put in for the
future it is very noticeable however
that your forecast is very different
from the bank of England's forecast and
I just wondered if you could talk us
through what you think are the major
differences in assumption that you've
taken there sure it is different from
that set out by the bank of England
although I I should emphasize the bank
of England to actually set out two
forecasts in it so um in its monetary
policy report so it's different from the
central one which of theirs which was
based on the market assumptions for the
future of bank rate
um it is uh more optimistic for the
growth Outlook than the bank's forecast
we have a we have a shorter recession
um and we recover to a higher level for
GDP than the bank
um I should emphasize how that it's more
or less in line with the forecast of
other other independent forecasters so
we're quite close to the consensus is
actually the bank which is a bit of an
outlier
um in being so pessimistic
um in particular about the length of the
recession
um that we that we both think has
already already begun I'm going into the
reasons for why our forecasts differ
it's really three things one is the
Vintage of data that we took in this
forecast versus the one done by the bank
a few days earlier we had we took a
slightly later vintage of both gas
prices and interest rate expectations
those had been coming down over the
course of race October and early
November and the later you went the more
you sort of got the benefit of those
both gas prices being slightly lower and
interest rates being slightly lower a
second important reason comes down to a
difference of judgment
um which is around the savings rate and
what will happen to the household
savings rate in response to this
unprecedented kind of once in a once in
a in a century shock to living standards
and that is that we think that the
savings rate is going to fall over the
course of the next few years
um or over the course the next year as
people dip into something dip into their
pandemic saving to support their
consumption over the course of the next
few quarters
um the bank thinks the savings rate is
going to go up because people are
holding on to more precautionary savings
because they're worried about the
outlook for their um for their their
incomes and their employment
um we will see who's right
um but I think given that this is an
unprecedented shock we thought it was
not unreasonable to think that people
might do purely a judgment call there's
no actual evidence base to make either
of those two assumptions oh it's based
on the models that we have
um and David might want to say might
want to say a bit more about it um but
it's it's something which um we see
unprecedented the high savings rates in
the recent past and when people were you
know had maintained incomes but were
able to spend the money given this is an
unprecedented shock to their earnings we
thought that it was not unreasonable to
assume that they might dip into some of
those same things to support their
consumption no it would be interesting
to hear from David on that and also um
on the assumptions that have been made
about the drivers of inflation and is it
correct that uh that all the forecasters
seem to be saying that inflation will
come down by the middle of next year I
think you've got inflation of about
seven percent for the year as a whole
can you talk us through some of those
assumptions as well very briefly thank
you on the on the savings rate I think
such is the hit to disposable income of
households
that it seemed to us plausible and
economic theory would suggest there's
something in this that faced with such a
fall in purchasing power which recovers
a little bit further down the road
it seemed likely that people might dip
into savings
added to the fact that in aggregate
anyway the household sector in the UK
largely results of the lockdowns in 2020
2021 accumulated a really large amount
of what you might call excess savings
savings that couldn't couldn't be
explained other than that people were
constrained being able to spend money
and that was of an order of 18 billion
pounds or so so it's a big number and
we've seen people those that can dip
into that those that haven't got
accumulated savings are in a more
difficult position but they may be able
to
extend mortgages a bit and use credit
cards and such and we assume that the
aggregate impact of that is actually to
take the savings rate to pretty much to
zero but did you have any evidence base
for that did you do any survey work well
what yeah underpin your work compared to
the bank's work on that I mean there is
some survey evidence people ask how are
you going to deal with higher energy
prices and other prices
and a significant proportion not a
majority but something from recollection
maybe 30 40 percent say they will dip
into savings if they can
so we assume that obviously not
everybody is able to do that but a
significant portion are I think just in
a longer term context there's a huge
amount of empirical evidence gathered
over many years that
temporary reductions in disposable
income tend to be matched by a lower
savings rate to some extent anyway
so we we use both those ideas really uh
and took the savings rate down
materially more than the bank of England
I think that's the most significant
factor so then the obvious follow-up
question to that
that are much more to the downside than
the banks
um
I'm I'm not I'm not sure about that
because if you look at what happened
with the savings rate in 2020 2021 I
think it got up to something like 25
that's an extraordinarily High savings
rate
we go down to zero essentially in this
forecast for for a short while
zero is about maybe five percent below
what you might call normal or average
over the last 10 20 years whereas 25 is
massively in excess of it so
in some sense we're only allowing for
some relatively small proportion of the
excess savings to be run down and I
think it may well be the case that the
total savings rate for the house will
take to is even lower than our forecast
so I don't think all the risks are on on
one side and then to my questions about
inflation yeah what the assumptions
there
I think the key the key factor in a
sense is the unwind partial unwind
anyway of what has driven inflation or
the primary factor that's driven
inflation up so much which is the
increase in energy places gas in
particular
we use the market forward rates which in
some sense are a market expectation
about where Energy prices might go and
we use the forward rates over the next
three years
and what they uh and would imply if
things turned out in line with those
Market expectations
is the there's a really substantial fall
in energy by the particularly gas prices
really starting relatively early next
year but accelerating really sharply as
you go through 2024 into 2025
even even if Energy prices didn't form
it just stayed where they were
because the rate of increase would would
become very small as you go into the
future if they just stayed flat that in
itself would very likely have brought
the inflation rate down a lot
but as I said those forward rates imply
that energy price is actually fall very
substantially something like 30 40
percent
between the middle of next year and
toward the end of 2024 and that is the
single most significant factor in
driving inflation down really quite
sharply in our forecast it actually
takes it slightly negative once you get
into 2025 before then moving back up
again
okay turning to business investment
um you're pretty gloomy about business
investment overall and you don't really
seem to think that any of the measures
that the chancellor announced the annual
investment allowance for example you
don't seem to assume that they're going
to have a massive impact on business
investment
no and business investment has been
pretty disappointing for a while in the
UK and with a shocked household incomes
a shock to consumption business
investment tends to track expectations
of future consumption so at least in the
near term
um given that we're forecasting a
consumption driven uh recession uh it's
um it's unlikely that you're going to
see lots of businesses investing into a
recession you've also got on top of that
an increase in the economy-wide cost of
capital from the fact that interest
rates have started to rise and that
means it's going to be harder for
businesses to raise Finance if they want
to do investment and the hurdle rate for
those Investments goes up at the same
time as your expectations of future
sales are going down
um and and the government now is going
ahead with the corporation tax Rises so
have they not done that that would have
provided some support to investment
um over the over the course of our
forecast but as that measures now
um now going ahead in the corporation
tax wise goes up that that then that
further reduces the post-tax return on
investment so all of that uh for the
period that we're looking at means of
business investment sort of stagnates a
few years before it starts to pick up
until the end of the forecast period as
as the economy recovers and also
interest rates start to come down and
come down a bit at least at the short
term and is it too early to say what the
impact of this
the suction on him for investment which
was designed to prevent sort of people
waiting until Corporation taxes went up
to invest is it too early to say if
that's had an impact um it's it's a bit
too early to say because it doesn't
close until I believe
um so it's still got a few months to run
I I when we last looked at it compared
to our original estimates we'd
overestimated take up and how much and
how much investment it was going to
stimulate
um I I it probably stands to reason
given all the uncertainty around the
economic Outlook that's now been created
by both higher energy prices and higher
interest rates that it's gonna that
increases the headwinds that it would
have to get over in order to incentivize
further investment but
um it's it's not been enough for us to
make a material difference to our
estimate of the kind of overall final
size of the Capital stock and and levels
of investment over the forecast period
which means that for us it doesn't have
a big big impact on on long-term growth
so any other points to make on why your
forecasts are so different from the
banks let me just one one final thing I
said there were three things one was the
Vintage of data the second was the
savings rate and the third is this our
final kind of steady state growth rate
uh for for the economy in the medium
term is higher than the banks we assume
in the long run at potential output
Grows by one and three quarter percent
the bank have a sort of trend growth
rate of one and a half percent so our
our economy after the recession is
recovering to a higher level a higher a
higher rate of growth
um in the long run than what's the
underlying reason for that
um it's it's a number of things uh it
it's partly uh assumptions about Labor
Force um it's it's mostly assumptions
about the pace of Technology growth
whereas
um the you can you could describe the
bank as a bit more sort of techno
pessimists
um compared to us we think that the rate
of growth in uh technological innovation
goes back to somewhere between its
pre-financial crisis and its
post-financial crisis average whereas
the bank believe that the financial
crisis was more of an auger of just a
lower level of innovation going on in
the world
um
okay Joan you had a quick question just
very briefly can I just press you on
your optimistic growth forecasts I mean
just withdrawing from the detail a
little bit
um if you look back at you know history
um previous periods Ryan periods of
rising interest rates High government
spending taxes rising and living
standards falling traditionally that's
been a mix for slower economic growth
not optimistic bands I mean why is it
different this time
I mean we would say it's different the
main reason is this uh
uh I've been here you were describing
you know what perhaps the the energy
shocks of the late 70s and early 80s
those shots lasted much longer than if
you believe what the markets are saying
about the Futures price of energy this
shock is going to last they've got
Energy prices coming back down quite
dramatically as as David was saying over
the course of next year which provides
some relief to the economy and makes
this
um more of a temporary shock in terms of
the where we started to the peak now now
it is the case that energy prices gas
prices in particular still remain much
higher for the medium term than they
were pre-pandemic but the economy is
already getting some relief over the
course of next year from falling gas
prices compared to the energy shocks of
the 70s and 80s where the oil price went
up
um and just stay Stayed high for years
and that act as it acted as a dragon on
economies and also we want to argue that
moderation policy was further behind
um in catching up and in reigning in
inflation expectations which also acted
um as a dragon as well as an investment
over for that period so I think it's
about reason that we think that this
would be we will we've got a five
quarter recession that's of a reasonable
duration
um but it's not like the sort of stag
fish new periods that other economies
have suffered when they've had and
they've had big energy
thank you no yeah very short very
briefly you mentioned that your sort of
techno-optimists are compared to the
bank I mean you would would you accept
that despite all the technology
um prowess of the states that their big
companies there and so forth and other
examples around the world it hasn't
actually significantly boosted
productivity or economic growth as far
as one can tell so that I guess all
countries are faced a Slowdown in their
productivity growth and part of which is
driven by seems to be driven by this
fact that the rate of technological
innovation has slowed
um and there are it's a puzzle for a
reason we don't we don't precisely know
why so you know some people surmise that
a lot of the innovation
in the last decade or so has been about
making consumer experiences more
enjoyable rather than making our
productive lives more productive and
that may even be attention between those
two things
you know the more diverting your phone
is
um the less you get done the less you
get done at work
um that may be the case
um it's something where we have to make
a judgment
um we've sort of Fallen somewhere in
between I think the people who are very
pessimistic about the outlook for
technological growth and those who think
that we're just going to at some point
go back to the world we were in in the
late 90s okay thank you
Danny are you
ready to go
thank you very much yeah I was going to
ask some questions about your
expectation or your the effect of the
changes to capital expenditure that
Chancellor announced um we're
maintaining
the investment that was planned for the
next two years but it's growth will slow
after that
can you just talk us through what you
think the impact on growth will be from
that and and there's a follow-up and
interesting whether you're distinguish
between different forms of capital
expenditures that the public sector
might be making in terms of effect on
growth if the taxes still has well two
apartments have the capacity to make
choices within the limits they've been
given and they're better and worse as
investment decisions they can make sure
um certainly I I suppose looking at the
uh the long Suite of History the UK has
traditionally been a has under invested
um from the public sector from one of
the public Investments um we've we've
net investment was under two percent of
GDP
um back in 2000 and and before then and
and so we've typically invested less
than two percent of GDP as a country in
terms of investment coming out of
government more recently and in
particular in the March 2020 budget at
the government set plans to increase the
public investment a lot
um and and which saw it reach two and a
half percent of GDP last year
um the government's plans of next three
years as you say are more or less
protected and it stays roughly around
those levels obviously GDP is jumping
around over the next few years but from
2025 26 onwards the government freezes
the capital budget for departments in
cash terms for the remaining three years
of the forecast and that means that the
share of public investment in the
economy drops from around two and a half
down to something more like 2.2 2.1 by
the end of our forecast period
um so it's it's it's it's constant in
cash terms of Performing as a hair of
the economy and falling in real terms
um
one thing to emphasize about is growth
effects is that it takes a very long
time for investment decisions to have an
impact on the long-run growth rate of
the economy if you just think about how
long it takes to build cross-rail hs2
these are 10 15 20 year projects they
don't have any economic they have a
small economic benefit to aggregate
demand while they're being built but the
main benefit they get is from putting a
new bit of network infrastructure into
the economy you don't get any of that
benefit until the product's finished so
you could have to wait 20 years and you
don't get the full benefit until you
wait the whole lifetime of the project
and probably also economic activity
starts to Cluster around it and so for
all of those reasons you don't get any
sort of immediate bang for your buck
from public investment what you do get
is the benefit of building up over time
a larger stock of public Capital than
you would otherwise have had otherwise
have had in the form of that Network
infrastructure we had assumed that based
on the government's plans back in back
in March of 2020 that that increase in
public sector net investment which at
the time was programmed in for about 0.7
of GDP was going to raise the public
sector Capital stock by about a quarter
so a big increase in other words it's a
25 increase in the overall stock of
public Capital by the time it ran its
course
um and in the period beyond their
forecast Horizon that could add 0.1
percentage points to the growth rate of
the economy in steady state
um uh given that the government is
pairing that back somewhat although not
entirely
um that will have an effect but it would
be beyond the forecast Horizon for this
document
um when we do our next 50-year
projections we'll have to we'll have to
think about what it means
um to have a lower level of investment
as the basis for those longer term
projections but in a given five-year
period anything government does with
with public infrastructure doesn't have
a big effect on our assessment of growth
because most of those projects barely
get started no I do appreciate that but
but it sends a signal doesn't it which
which uh will affect wider sentiment and
you mentioned low business investment
which is a chronic problem in our
economy I mean do you is there an
Evidence link between public investment
and private and do you think that the
decision to slow the growth in public
has been a public investment might
discourage Private Business investment
which might have a quicker return than
these big public employees it's one of
the things that goes into our
calculation of the gearing ratio between
public investment and overall growth so
it's not just the benefit of people
being able to get from one place to
another more quickly but it that it also
um sort of bails in private investment
as well but but as I said only over a
very long period and only if it's only
if it's a statement and I think one of
the dangers we always come under
pressure to say why don't you give the
government more growth benefit
um uh for its investment decisions and
it's partly because the decisions don't
get sustained yeah
um you know governments oftentimes reach
for the capital lever as a way of
reducing the deficit when they can and
it means that if we base a forecast on
an assumption that government is going
to maintain a high level Capital
spending for the whole five years and
they don't do it
um well then they don't get the growth
that we were assuming in the forecast
um we haven't revised on growth to take
account of a lower public Capital stock
because basically the effects are so
marginal in a five-year period but when
we come back to our next set of
long-term objections and what about the
different sorts of capitalists I mean
would you prioritize you know trains
over Broadband or not really and and
sort of for the reasons that for the
same reasons which is we don't actually
know what the government's going to be
spending its money on in five years time
and we have a we have a rough sense
there are some there are some projects
um that have been committed but um in
five years time it could be on hospitals
it could be on trains it could be on
something okay
one more question
um moving away from just purely capital
expenditure
um sort of this awful question for you
really you know what is the optimum size
of public expenditure because I you know
we we read the book
growth despite cuts to budget property
what mental budget is
size of its expenditures proportion of
the economy is growing significantly
because 39 to 43 percent
probably this was a small GDP uh
um and probably it's the cost of
borrowing so this isn't a sense not kind
of real money but but it matters in
terms of the share of of the productive
part of the economy I mean what is your
sense of the impact of
as it were the kind of gross tax take on
medium and longer term growth so it
would be Optimum what would be the
option of the size of the government in
your view so we try and stay out of
philosophical questions in the OVR
because we're not philosophers um you
know we're we're forecasters
um and
um
but it is the case for for a country
like the UK we have a tax-funded Health
Service
um we have we have an inflation effect
pension and we have a lot of debt and a
lot of what is driving the growth and
the size of the state over this forecast
and has actually uh driven a growth in
the size of the sake of a successive
forecast has been those three things
um have been getting much more expensive
because interest rates are higher
um inflation is higher and we just have
a much much higher debt stock than we
are than we have been used to we used to
have a 30 densityp ratio in this country
we now have 100 density GP ratio and
when interest rates triple on that it
just hits it just hits government
spending very quickly
um and so the government has taken some
offsetting action by cutting as we've
discussed Capital spending by by cutting
by reducing the growth rate of
departmental current spending but there
was very little it could do with it if
it wanted to honor it it's inflation
promise on the welfare system if it
wanted to keep servicing its debts
um then then there was little do for
those elements of expenditure but try
and offset them elsewhere and it had a
fiscal objective to get the deficit blue
three percent and get debt falling and
that implied the tax burden that we got
um we haven't looking at the individual
tax measures
um we haven't assumed any long-run drag
on the growth rate basically because you
had offsetting effects
um you had some tax measures that are
slightly improved incentives to provide
additional labor
um to the market and then other tax
changes like the freezes to thresholds
which which basically dulled those
incentives and we concluded at the end
of looking at that it was not in net
terms of material effect on on labor
Angela thank you
um you've said you've made it clear to
the committee that you had a forecast up
and ready that had been updated all the
way through summer up and ready to go
when did you discover that causing and
Liz truss were proposing to deliver
their mini budget without using your
services was it at the very last minute
um no we were we were informed and it's
actually set out in the forward to our
um uh to our documents so we were
informed on the 7th of September
um that the chancellor was not going to
be commissioning a forecast uh from us
to accompany the announcements they were
going to make later that month and did
they give you a reason why or did they
just
dispense with your services by letter uh
they they said that they were
commissioner forecast from us later in
the year and when they made their
announcements on the 23rd of September
um they said that they were going to
commission a forecast from us uh by the
end of the calendar year and did you
have any kind of
um exchange with them about how
dangerous doing that might be given that
clearly the the so-called growth
strategy was a fiscal event uh we had no
discussions with the chancellor or the
Prime Minister do you think that there
are any Pro I was actually prior to
prior to the 23rd of September we met
with them when you met yeah that was
famously shown walking down Downing
Street
amidst the rubble
um
there are only lessons you think need to
be learned about this episode do we need
a better definition of budget or fiscal
event
um uh you know other are there some
things that might protect your position
that Parliament ought to be thinking
about in terms of changing legislation
so the committee in its own reports has
has commented on the growing tendency in
UK for policy making for major policy
announcements to happen without
forecasts and it's almost the budgets
have become unmoored from where they
used to be and we've had a sort of
trickle of them all the way through the
year it's through and I think one one
can't be too critical of specific
instances because there were cases like
in March of 2020 my predecessor had just
produced a forecast and then the
pandemic hit and then shortly after that
reaching soon everybody was trying to
announce a further scheme I think he was
perfectly legitimate that he needed to
move at PACE
um we then worked very quickly
um to then produce an updated forecast
as the basis for the next round of
position taking but you obviously don't
want to wait for us if you've got to get
something like the further scheme in
place when people are facing losing
their jobs but there have been other
instances where essentially
discretionary fiscal policy decisions
have been made without forecasts uh you
know the Health and Social care Levy and
the health settlement alongside it was
was an example
um I mean five fiscal events since March
you detail in your yes and and good
practice as defined by anyone not just
us but by International organizations
that set standards for these things
would say that you shouldn't make fiscal
decisions without them being informed by
them an Upstate view of the economic
output I just want to spend a little bit
of time talking about the change of
fiscal targets and the reduced Headroom
there I think since 2010
um conservative chancellors have broken
their fiscal rules 11 times
um this Autumn statement breaks the
fiscal rule that was put into place last
November by over I think 11 and a half
billion you you say in your report and
it also breaks the current balance
Target as well by 8.7 billion
um
what are your thoughts about moving to a
five-year rolling forecast and and it's
been called the manana
um fiscal rule do you think it's useful
so we so one thing to say is that uh it
wasn't just that all chancellors have
have ended up breaking their physical
rules with a few exceptions
um since they were since they we first
started having them in the late in in
the late 90s when they were first first
set by Gordon Brown I remember it well
um and we seem to we seem to be moving
to a system where fiscal rules are a
guide for fiscal policy making at the
time rather than something which exposed
you can hold them to account for having
met and that and that that was
originally the case when rules were his
chances were on track to meet their
targets and then they broke them and
then they sort of didn't do anything
about it and then they set a new set of
targets after an election so
um the the timetable for fiscal policy
making and the timetable for political
decision making
um you know weren't weren't particularly
well aligned
um
I do think there's nothing wrong with a
system where you use your fiscal rules
as a guy propose making but it just
means that you put a lot of weight on
the forecast to tell you whether you're
on track rather than putting weight on
the ons to tell you in out term data
whether whether you're so it's more
about having a fiscal rule that's
attached to a forecast that tells you
you're on track rather than actually
looking at the actual outcome isn't it
and the perhaps the longer the fiscal
rules take to be judged five years now a
an increase of two years the less likely
that Chancellor is likely to be around
to take the Flack for the Judgment
surely that that's right although I
would also stress that we've been
through a period of extraordinary
volatility in the last few years we've
had a pandemic we've now got an energy
crisis
um it you would you would probably need
to do some quite perverse things with
fiscal policy in order to meet your
fiscal Targets in those kind of contexts
um given what's happening to the economy
so it is probably a right a right thing
to do to reassess what targets set
yourself in light of the new New
Economic Outlook but the other thing
that I should say is that if we are in a
world of where shocks are becoming
increasingly frequent and and serious
and you are concerned about the level of
debt and its affordability then you need
to aim off a lot more for those shocks
when they when they do happen and it has
been a pattern of behavior of all
chancellors that they leave themselves
you know as they have again with these
targets you know a few tens of billions
of pounds in Headroom against a fiscal
Target in five years time which is a
tiny fraction of our forecast error over
that time of horizon
um and given what we now know about
where Shocks come from given what we
know about the sensitivity of our public
finances to interest rates to inflation
these are very very small margins and if
you're serious about actually getting
debt down and out tone in five years
time you probably want a lot more than
than the nine billion pounds of the
chances 0.3 percent of GDP but I think a
point four percent increase in interest
rates would wipe it out yes
yeah it's um yeah okay
um debt interest spending more than
doubles in cash terms
from 56.4 billion which is two and a
half percent of GDP uh last year to Peak
at
120.4 billion this year which is nearly
five percent of GDP
I think that's the highest since
immediately following the Second World
War
who were the main beneficiaries of their
interests that the government's paying
out are these bondholders or I hope that
were there people who own government
debt
um they are the largest group of people
who are up people in Pension funds and
insurance funds um they're the people
who have long-term fixed instruments
um about a quarter of our debt is now
own abroad so foreigners are also
benefiting um from this foreign central
banks foreign investors looking for for
fixed term fixed terminal Investments
questions on this as well um a bit
further down there's a note in the
that the debt stock inflation linked
bonds have quadrupled from six percent
to 22 percent
uh and that the bank is quantitative
easing operations have reduced the
maturity of government debt in hindsight
could the government or the bank of
England have made decisions which would
have reduced the debt interest cost for
the government
um so it is it is the case that one of
the reasons why there's such a dramatic
increase in debt interest costs in our
forecast is is two things one is we've
got much more inflation link debt than
other countries which means that when
inflation goes up that just increases
our borrowing costs immediately
compared to other countries who have
more of an opportunity to allow
inflation to erode the nominal value of
that of that debt away it's also the
case that one of the side effects of
quantitative easing has been that it's
shortened the effective maturity of our
deaths because the bank of England's
brought up long-term government debt and
replaced it with its own short-term
interest and because we consolidate both
together when we think about the public
sector it means that the net maturity of
our debt is shortened dramatically from
about seven years down to two and that
just means that any rise in inflation
any rise interest rates just hits the
public finances a lot more quick
because you're not waiting to refinance
very much again this has been happened
almost by accident because it makes the
whole situation much more volatile and
the the price is much more sensitive to
we've been changes I mean it is it is it
is a side effect of of monetary policy
I'm not saying it's wrong I'm not saying
it's not necessarily a price worth
paying it wasn't asking you whether it
was wrong it's an issue which we've
highlighted a lot and and but it pains
to discuss for many years and we've
talked to this committee about it and uh
you know we've highlighted the risks
that come from having shortening the
effect of maturity of debt as much as we
have and in this forecast you've seen
you've seen the consequences but could I
just ask a brief question about uh uh
fuel Duty which you you also highlight
in your report and you point out there's
a plan 20 23 increase in the fuel Duty
rate which is due in late March when um
when the five percent cut which was
temporary exits and the
um the assumptions
um about a fuel Duty sort of escalator
also come in the government of yesterday
in the debate in the house seemed to be
saying that this wouldn't be happening
um so why is it in your forecasts and
what amount of money would the
government have to find if it decided
not to go ahead with that hit to fuel
Duty so our forecast is based on
government policy which was announced
back in March which was that there's
going to be a 5p cut to fuel duty this
year but then it was going to be made up
from April next year um which means that
on top of the usual RPI indexation you
would add 5p on top of that
um that was a policy that that was that
was the policy as it was set back in
March it was the policy as confirmed by
the treasury when they gave us the
policy assumptions to use for this
document
um when we produced it uh this month
um and will the government to not go
ahead with that policy it would mean
that it loses around 6 billion pounds
from the sort of super indexation of
fuel Duty from April that said
um hardly any chances but since 2010 no
chancellor has gone ahead with the
planned indexation of fuel Duty when the
time comes and they actually they
actually have to make the decision they
tend to decide to freeze this but
oftentimes they leave that assumption in
there for a period because it makes the
forecast look healthier um then out turn
out turns out to be because
um if you're faced with the decision
um come next march they may make a
difference so if they do that just
finally that means that they've got to
find another six billion for the
scorecard to even keep the books in the
situation they're written down yes okay
okay thank you Angela
thank you um I've got some questions on
fiscal consolidation the chancellor
emphasized in his Autumn statement that
with under half the 55 billion
consolidation coming from taxon just
over half from spending this is a
balanced plan for stability looking at
the overall picture What proportion of
the government's fiscal consolidation
overall would you say comes from tax and
spending and how does this compare with
the fiscal consolidation of 2010.
foreign
so um there's a there's a few ways of
looking at this because
um in terms of the measures that this
chancellor has announced in the Autumn
statement and also the decision not to
go ahead with cutting the basic rate of
income tax on the 17th
that in our forecast adds up to 62
billion in the finals can you say that
again it adds up to 62 billion in the
final year of the forecast which is
precisely half and half tax and spending
um the the difference with the
treasury's numbers is they they
separated out of that basic rate income
tax measure so that's why they get the
55 rather than 62 but let's not split
hairs
looking at things relative to policy as
it stood in March so how it has changed
our forecasts
um the consolidation is worth about 40
billion pounds in the final year and
that's simply because part of this
Chancellor's consolidation is to cover
the surviving tax cuts from the growth
plan which Health and Social care Levy
is by far the largest so that
consolidation is about a quarter tax and
about three-quarters spending
um perhaps the more pertinent
measure is what will happen rather than
considering it relative to a baseline of
a different set of policies what is
planned to happen over the next uh over
the median term so if you look at
spending and tax relative to where they
stood in 2019
spending Rises by about four percent of
GDP in eight years and so does the tax
burden
though
in that sense it's an expansion of both
state and tax burden over over that
period now if you compare it back to
what happened
in 2010 both what was planned over five
years and I guess what was delivered
over about eight years
um
the the share was about 80 spending and
about 20 tax and also in in a sense it
it led to a shrinking of the state and
very very modest rise in the tax burden
through raising vat
okay
um we were we were promised by a few
chancellors ago but I forget which one
the austerity was over but Authority is
clearly back now from what you said uh
and the ifs
said that the British people have just
got a lot poorer the bank of England
Governor when he came and gave evidence
that
uh that
the U.S obviously has grown uh by 4.2
since the pandemic the GDP of the
Eurozone countries is 2.1 percent and
yet the UK economy is at 0.7 it's
smaller than at the start of the
pandemic these are these are very
worrying numbers for us uh obviously he
also talked about particular shocks
um Paul Johnson talks about talks about
earned goals
the current the statement Autumn
statement has uh
stabilize things perhaps
um in the light of the Fiasco of the
mini budget the Esco in your
organization being left out of the loop
um how do we get out of this Doom Loop
uh what should happen in terms of create
generating growth and all the steps that
have been taken insufficient to be able
to get at get us out of this hellhole
that we're in
um we need to be careful about providing
positive advice to either government or
this committee but um in terms of what
we're currently assuming about the
growth Outlook and maybe what is what is
holding that back David do you want to
see it
I think relative to where we were in
March which was not a particularly
comfortable position to be an evening in
March because Energy prices have already
gone up quite a bit
and the recovery from the
pandemic was being held back slightly by
a much lower labor Supply than we
thought so even in March things were not
um tremendously optimistic in terms of
the Outlook but but the things that have
really happened since then I think
explain
the scale of the shock
to the population in the UK and they are
uh increases in interest rates of a
scale that simply wasn't on the cards
back in March and a further but very
large increase in Energy prices so if it
and just sorry just on the increase in
interest rates yes you're referring to
what happened in September and having a
material obviously we've had the monthly
increase anyway before September yes I
mean could you just yes absolutely
what happened in September was an
increase they'd been then an increase in
interest rates which was significantly
higher in the UK than in most other
industrialized Western countries yeah
but that what you might call excess
increase in interest rates in the UK has
all but disappeared yep now so by the
time we do our Autumn statement obr
forecast
really what's happened is that the
increase in interest rates in the UK
looks pretty much in line with the
global increase in interest rates but
it's very big
just just as an illustration of that if
you took 10-year government bond yields
that we had back at the time of
um March
they were about 1.3 1.4 percent and
financial markets were expecting that
that's where they'd stay pretty much
by the time we came to do the
um forecast a couple of weeks ago
they were 3.6 so it wasn't far off a
tripling in interest rates and given the
stock a debt
that households own under the governor
owns
um that's a very big hit uh indeed
the energy price increase also very
large so
again if you go back to the time of
March
Market expectations for where gas prices
were going to be on average in 2023 back
in March
were very much lower than they are right
now so right now they're about 80
percent higher
in the global markets this has affected
anybody who who Imports gas
so I think I think those are the two big
things that have made the UK coming back
to Paul Johnson's statement about the UK
just got the people of the UK just got
poorer I mean those are the two reasons
why
it happened
I think the good news is
that
it's plausible that both of those
effects
will be somewhat attenuated as you look
into the future and I already mentioned
that if you look at the financial Market
projections as to where Energy prices go
actually they fall back quite a lot over
the next couple of years that's very
good for households it's very good for
companies in the UK and
even in the short period since we
produced the forecast interest rates
have continued to move down a little bit
and the projections for where Bank of
England bank rate is have always been a
little bit lower two or three years down
the road and our own projections for
where mortgage rates go is that it might
Peak the average interest rate on the
stock of mortgages will go up for a
while
but then it will turn the corner and
start heading back downwards again based
on Market forecast for where interest
rates will go so I think we're
20 23 is going to be a very difficult
year very likely but the years after it
will not be quite as bad
thank you um so just going on to public
sector next day excluding the bank of
England and the underlying measures of
debt uh it rises to Peak to a peak of
97.6 of GDP in 20 25 to 26 before
falling
um can you talk us through what the
trigger would be triggers would be which
would enable UK public debt to fall as a
proportion of GDP
and so there's two reasons why public
debt turns around uh towards the end of
the forecast one is that as Energy
prices and interest rates fall although
remaining higher than previously assumed
that gives support to the economy
so
um you know if you think of energy
prices as the the price of an essential
it's it's almost like a tax rise that
we're facing at the moment and it's
almost like a tax cut when there's
Energy prices fall back and so that
recovery in GDP growth means that debt
over GDP the GDP is growing more
strongly and that helps
um the second reason is the fiscal
consolidation measures that were taken
in the Autumn statement which are enough
to bring borrowing down sufficiently
that debt Rises more slowly than GDP so
without those measures that would have
risen
um you know forevermore with them it
stabilizes and it you know Falls by a
very tiny margin in there
at the end of the forecast okay just one
more question which uh just wanted to
see if you concur yesterday the chief
Economist of Pantheon economics said
that the the number of people who are
out of work because of being on the NHS
waiting list
um there are about uh that
the since 2020 we've seen a rise of
roughly 400 000 in the number of people
who are of working age but economically
inactive
um and that's about 1.2 percent hit of a
hit on the size of the workforce
um when pushed he thought that it could
be a 0.7 hit to the workforce in terms
of output do you would you um would you
agree with those figures
and so it's it it's certainly the case
that our the one of the as David was
mentioning one of the reasons why we I I
on top of the reasons David gave another
reason why we came out of the pandemic
um with a lower level of output and
we're going into this next Crisis from a
lower level of output than other
countries is that we've been we've been
a bit unusual in seeing rates of late
Market inactivity go up after the
pandemic for a lot of other advanced
economies they actually saw labor
participation rise so inactivity fall in
the wake of the pandemic but nobody
really understands entirely why that's
why that's happened in those countries
and why we've had the opposite effect
um the reasons do appear to be complex
there's a mixture of Health factors
there seems to be a strong element of
early retirement
um given the age profile of people who
left labor force during the pandemic and
are now not reappearing afterwards
um to the extent that
um a large number of those people are of
all in the older age group we're we're
very pessimistic about their prospects
for rejoining the labor market over the
course of the forecast that we have here
we have some return
um but not very many so you're still
losing hundreds of thousands of people
from the labor force from some
combination of ill health early
retirement
um and and other factors
um that appear to have come to pass
during the pandemic and it it is
something which holds back
so so some of those people do want to
return to the labor market which could
to the question was about this 0.7 hit
it's something that we want to look into
I I it would be wrong of us to pretend
that we we know the Dynamics of this
it's something that we we definitely
want to look in into in more detail
because our forecast here24 have been
based on uh what had been more
optimistic assumptions about returns to
the labor market
um I think we want to better understand
both what the data says about why
they're out in the labor market and and
also what the evidence says about why
they're why they're coming back in we we
will look at it in more detail but we
even get a chance to win this thank you
thank you so much Anthony thank you
chair
um so my questions at least initially
are about departmental spending uh so uh
except for schools and hospitals the
departmental the normal Department
mental spending was kept the same for
the next two years as it was under the
uh previously under the comprehensive
spending review
um but inflation is obviously a lot
higher than it was when that review came
out how tough is that going to be how
much savings do the Department's gonna
have to make
um so it so the the government has
topped up the budgets of Health social
care and it ends and schools um over the
next over the years spending plans of
setting cash terms going out to 2024-25
but for the reading departments they are
there in essence being asked to can you
know to absorb the hit from higher
inflation I I mean we should stress that
you there is there is a debate about
what's the right inflation index to use
to measure the inflation pressures of
departments is probably not as high as
the double-digit CPI figure but it's
also probably not as low because wages
won't be going up as hard as that's all
because the biggest Department's biggest
cost is Workforce and wages really going
up by five six percent you know
government departments don't feed people
they don't have to worry about the food
price although they're certainly their
employees do
um but they don't view it directly they
feel it through
um what help what they have to pay their
employees for for wages so in the near
term departments are facing a squeeze
from higher inflation and then beyond
over the current spending of you period
from 20 25 26 the government has taken
some cash out of their spending plans
they they took
um about 18 billion pounds out of
resource budgets at about 12 billion
pounds out of capital budgets that means
that the growth rate of spending Beyond
2024-25 Falls yeah so it was good it was
going basically in line with the economy
around two and a half percent
um now down now down to one percent that
takes about 30 billion in total out of
both well current and capital spending
combined so just in terms of that sort
of focus on that first bit first the
inflate absorbing the help from
inflation how how difficult or hard is
it going to be for the Departments to do
that apart from health education
um so it will be difficult
um and uh and there is there is you know
as part of the sort of due diligence of
the forecast that we do we talk to uh
Finance directors and departments to ask
what kind of choices would you would you
have to make their assessment is that it
is it's sort of tough but deliverable
um but it means that basically they
can't do all the things that they want
to do um in the near term
um and some departments as I said are
getting are getting additional support
for for absorbing those costs whereas
others do
so beyond that coming to the one percent
increase in spending longer term which
obviously shrink spending also share of
the economy overall assuming the economy
grows more than one percent
um you some people have said that's
impossible it's not going to happen I
think you described it as plausible uh
how difficult is it going to be to meet
that spending and so the reason we
describe it as plausible is obviously
the government doesn't have detailed
spending plans Beyond 2024-25 so we
don't know what the allocation of
spending looks like beyond that
um the government does have commitments
that it's made on defense and overseas
aid to grow those in line with GDP so
those are growing at two and a half
compared to an envelope growing at one
that squeezes the resources available to
the rest
um per pupil the government's got
equipment on per pupil spent real growth
in the per pupil spending in schools
which we assume is also a met and then
we make a sort of historical
extrapolation of the growth rate and
health spending of just over three
percent
um within that to look at basically what
resources are left over for other
departments that aren't covered by some
kind of some kind of pre-existing
protection and what it would mean is
that their budgets Fall by about 0.7 per
year in real terms and the reason why we
say that's plausible is that yes it's a
real cut in those departments but it's
not it's actually lower than what
they've seen in some previous spending
rounds in the spending of views of 2010
and 2015 that group of departments were
facing cuts of three to five percent in
real terms per year in their budgets so
this is to make it less than that which
is why we think it's plausible the thing
which kind of weighs against it is it's
always the same group of departments
that seem to be asked to be bearing the
brunt of of real Cuts in their budgets
this would be yet another spending of
you where they're the kind of Cinderella
departments um rather than the ones um
getting getting real growth in their
budgets and they have to absorb sort of
further further real reductions um in
their expenditure I think the other
thing to bear in mind is that while the
government has taken 30 billion pounds
out of spending
um in this forecast chances also have a
tendency to put around 30 billion pounds
back into public spending as the as the
moment doing a spending of you
approaches and yeah yeah and they have
they actually have to allocate that
envelope out
um around the cabinet table so I think
in the back of our minds we also
recognize that this may well propose a
uh quite a plausible risk to the Outlook
um by the time you get to the mid-2020s
so the
um various people not least in the labor
party including colleagues on this
committee have declared it's a new age
of austerity but how in numbers how does
uh the this constraint on public
spending compared to what happened in
2010 and 2015.
um so public spending is growing by less
um but the
um but the the rate of growth is still
higher than you've been invest in those
periods as Andy was mentioning during
that period you actually had the a
slight fall in public
as a share of GDP
um and and you know the pressure we we
measure it as the as the pressure that
it sort of leaves for this unprotected
group
um and it is on the order of minus 0.7 a
year compared to -3 minus five during
those periods but again there's a sort
of at some point you must you get to a
sort of limit on how much how much pain
you can continue to impose on the same
the same thing so it's uh I mean that's
a fraction of the restrictions that can
the
contraction there was previously the
governor it's like a fifth
it is more a yes but it's still a real
cut on a bunch of departments that have
previously faced real Cuts so would you
call this nature of austerity uh those
are other people's words
those sorts of words are not they're not
economic words and they're not words
that we tend to use
it's it's just it's not the same as what
happened to 2010 or 2015. the the
um uh you obviously you're predicting
inflation being very low indeed negative
for uh deflation
um towards this what happens if
inflation isn't that low
uh what's going to happen to the the
ability to meet those spending targets
then it makes it it makes it
um more difficult in two ways one is it
increases the financial pressure on the
Departments themselves but it will also
increase the financial pressure
um on government we've talked about how
they have inflation linked uh debt
commitments they have inflation linked
uh welfare payments um and inflation
turns out to be higher there may also be
an interest rate reaction which would
put the percentage pressure on
government so this whole forecast is
privileged on getting inflation under
control
um over the forecast period and getting
it back into single digits quite quickly
very quickly
um if that doesn't happen then that that
very much adds to the government's
fiscal worries both in the sort of in
the in microeconic terms but also in
Microsoft they're coming to um pensions
and uh uh benefits the uh the pension
triple lock-offs to the governments has
recommitted itself to that
um how and I think that's been that's
been welcomed by MPS across the house
how sustainable do you think that is in
the long run because isn't it inevitable
that at some point it'll have to move
it'll just increase the share of the
economy that's given those dimensions
yes um excuse me
um our long-term projections for a very
long time have shown how the triple lock
ratchets up
State Pension spending as a share of GDP
which is already
Rising due to the Aging population
um it's the it is the 2.5 floor out of
the triple lock that is really the
element of it that pushes uh pushes
spending up and it binds in three of the
I think it's either two or three of the
years in this forecast pushing spending
on position of GDP
um the uh the difficult thing about it
is that the lower productivity growth is
in the economy the more often two and a
half percent will be the highest of
three numbers and the more often
spending will rise as a share of GDP so
it is a it is a big pressure on the
long-term public finances and is it
sustainable long term
uh it would be sustainable if something
else gives
um so the way we do the long-term
projections is we we lay out the
implications of policy
and uh some you know long-term
assumptions about health spending which
show the public finances on a entirely
unsustainable path over the long term
um that's unlikely to happen of course
because something will give but it
illustrates the choices that will have
to be made if if the triple lock is to
be maintained for decades then it will
cause public spending to rise and then
obviously there's choices about does
other public spending for all the taxes
rise does poor own rise so your forecast
for welfare spending overall was 19
billion pounds a year more than you
previously forecast in March
um and that was I think mainly inflation
but were there other factors there and
how inevitable or how foreseeable was it
um yes so around half a little under
half of it was inflation uh being higher
than we expected in March and also the
triple lock binding so
um triple lock up rating pushing Upstate
pension spending
um a little of it is the the cost of
living payments at the start which
grouped under that heading
um but then there is a big chunk of it
that is related to what we were talking
about earlier in terms of kind of ill
health in the labor market uh showing up
pretty similarly in health related and
disability related benefits
and uh that adds up to you know almost
eight eight billion ish by the
uh medium term now
um was that foreseeable well we didn't
foresee it back in March I think what
what we've seen over the the months in
between is
um they have been very high inflows into
the disability benefit system
um which we're running at about 40 000 a
month pre-pandemic around 70 000 a month
this year
we'd always expected there to be some
pickup after a Health crisis and the
difficulty in administering the system
through the pandemic but it's been
higher than we thought and seems to be
more persistent
and there seems to be something similar
happening within Universal Credit in
health related elements of it
um the upward revision is large
we have had some in the past where the
systems were changing and we you know
got got things wrong about how that
would affect spending but this is
it seems to be related at least in some
way to what's happening in the labor
market and you know possibly to what's
happening with the NHS waiting list so
it's it's really something that's on our
kind of priority list for trying to
understand a bit better how closely
these things are tied and whether the
causes are the same or whether it's
coincidence that we're seeing it in
different places in the forecast and the
final last question because I'm running
out of time quickly on the main risks to
this on the upside on the in terms of
the welfare budget because the increased
economic activity if inflation it
doesn't come down as quickly as you
expect it to isn't there quite a big
risk that welfare spending will
overshoot
I mean I think the risks are in both
directions if if inflation comes down
faster the the opposite would be true
um in terms of this what we've done to
the health and disability benefits
um we now assume that these caseloads
rise as a share of the population
throughout the median term so you could
think you know hopefully that might be
pessimistic but that seems to be what
the data are showing us at the moment
okay thank you so much Anthony and Emma
yeah thank you chair and good afternoon
I'm not sure how closely you've been
following Northern Powerhouse rail but
you will have seen perhaps that it was
in the conservative Manifesto in 2019
taken out by Boyce Johnson put back in
by prime minister Elizabeth and take him
out again at the most recent budget and
this was all part of the Chancellor's
decision to keep the capital spending
flat Beyond uh 24
25. and so I just I just wondered if
you're able to tell us now or in in
writing what the impact of keeping that
Capital spend flat from 24 25 would have
a nominal or real GDP interest rates and
tax revenues but if you're happy for you
to put that in writing if you're not
even happy to be happy to put it in
writing I guess just in in outline terms
of what it what it means is that the
full increase in public investment that
was planned back in March of 2020 which
saw
about a 0.7 percent of GDP increase in
public investment which sounds like a
little bit but it only it only it
started below too so
um in as a share of total investment
that was a very big increase in in the
volume public investment compared to
what we're used to doing in the UK
um that that would have in the long run
increase the public sector Capital stock
by around a quarter and it would have
increased the long run growth rate of UK
in the long run now I mean long run as
well beyond the five-year period in this
forecast
um by by Norfolk one percent
um given that we have given that some of
that has now been paired back
um and when it comes when we come time
to do our long-term forecast again we
will need to reassess how much of that
Capital stock we now expect to be there
and how much growth will that be
supporting
um but but it's also the case that the
direction will be negative for for
growth and for and for productivity in
future because
less less Capital supporting less
economic activity in the world okay are
you able to say anything right now on
the impacts it would have on interest
rates or tax revenues or do you want to
put that in uh let us let us do a proper
proper answer that rather than me guess
off the top of my head but um uh but the
effects on interest rates probably a
minor if not zero um in terms of tax
revenue is a smaller economy generates
Less in terms of tax revenue so you
would like to reserve it thank you very
much um in the statement the chancellor
claimed that our actions today help
inflation fall sharply from the middle
of next year but I was just reading
earlier so excuse me for reading it off
my phone that the oecd have actually
said
um have actually laid some of the blame
for the UK's poor performance on the
energy price guarantee guarantee and
that they think the oecd warns that it
will add to overall demand in the
economy increasing inflationary
pressures in the medium terms of the
oecd saying that the energy price
guarantee is going to increase inflation
and the chancellor saying in his
statement that his actions today are
helping to decrease inflation so who's
right
the difference
well it decreases inflation it pretty
much in a guaranteed way that one can
quantify quite well I think which is you
know how much higher would energy bills
be to households and that would feed
through to Consumer Price inflation and
that would be something like two and a
half percent higher in the relatively
near term so instead of inflation being
around about 11 percent
now and into the early part of next year
that would have been 13 and a half maybe
even 14 so I think that that bit is
pretty easy to quantify
I'm not quite convinced by the oecd
argument that it it also causes
inflation that there's an offset to that
because inflation's higher I mean it's
true that the support measures to
households to companies as well
um is expensive fiscally
it adds up to something like 100 billion
pounds over the next
um 18 months or so that's extra spending
power in the hands of households and
companies
actually the way I would describe that
is it makes the recession shallower than
it otherwise would have been
that might have some marginal impact
because unemployment would have been
higher without that maybe week seven
months would have been a little bit
higher but I mean to my mind anyway that
those are all kind of second order
things whereas the first order thing is
you could pretty much guarantee
inflation would would have been
um you know thirteen and a half 14 in
the near term without without the
support package okay
okay for your comments on it they've
said better targeting of measures to
cushion the impact of high energy prices
would lower the budgetary cost better
preserve incentives to save energy and
reduce the pressure on demand that
attire of high inflation are they right
well I think it's a slightly strange way
to put it the the final point they make
about pressure on demand
um we're going to have a recession
almost certainly next year we're
probably at the optimistic end of the
spectrum and thinking it's going to be
relatively shallow but it still opens up
a degree of what you might call slack
spare capacity insufficient demand
frankly in the economy and
the support measures make that less less
bad than it otherwise would have been
so I I find the oecd description a
little bit strange to be honest
interesting so looking beyond the energy
price guarantees of putting that to one
side does the fiscal consolidation in
general in the budget in the statement
help to bring down inflation through
throughout the forecast
well I think I think I think the sort of
strategy
um
to give an enormous amount of support to
households and companies in the near
term over the next 12 18 months or so
which which has a logic to it in the
sense because that's when they hit to
people's budgets is greatest when the
reduction in demand otherwise would have
been even bigger when real disposable
incomes which already we think for
something like seven percent over the
next couple of years would have been
even bigger it would have been more like
a 10 fall and you kind of claw the money
back towards the the back end of the
forecast further down the road
uh
so again I mean it's true that if you if
you didn't have that strategy and you
didn't provide that much support in the
short run
inflation might be a bit lower because
unemployment will be that much higher
and the recession will be that much
deeper whether or not one thinks that's
a good trade-off to make
um I'm not sure I'm not convinced myself
but yeah okay that's that's really
interesting thank you
um so you've you've got inflation
falling into negative territory from
2024 which is way below the bank's two
percent Target does this suggest that
the market forecasts for interest rates
on which you base your own forecast are
too high as the monetary policy
committee themselves suggested at their
November meeting
yes I mean but Ben broadband's
um typically one of the deputy comes to
the bank uh before the November monetary
policy decision made a speech mentioned
she made it very clear that at that time
he felt
with some justification I think that the
the market expectations of where bank
rate were going to go were too high
and they subsequently dropped back a bit
and we captured a significant part of
that in our own projections we just use
what the market expectations were for
bank rate by
um early November
or late October
as you rightly say plugging those into
our models we get inflation dropping
down to zero and becoming very mildly
negative for most of 2025.
and you might look at that and say well
that just says the bank of England's not
going to leave interest rates at the
level of the market implies if you get
down to those low levels of inflation
I'm not so sure about that because
the bank of England I mean quite rightly
look has a tendency to look through
temporary
big over sheets and under sheets of
inflation so they're doing it right now
I mean inflation is 11 Bank of England
is not setting an interest rate to bring
inflation down to two percent by
Christmas because if they did they'd
need interest rates at 10 and they know
that that would be dreadful for the
economy and the chances are I mean on
the bank's own forecast inflation does
come back then in fact the banks four
guys as inflation drops down to pretty
much close to zero for a short while a
little bit further down the road
so I think what what the monetary policy
committee strategy is makes a lot of
sense which is if you think that
inflation has moved away from the target
for a few quarters maybe even four or
five quarters but it's going to come
back
don't add to everybody's Worlds by
moving interest rates dramatically to
try and bring it back really quickly
and that's what they're doing right now
pretty clearly and I suppose our
forecast implies that they do something
similar on the other side of it if
inflation temporarily drops down to zero
or maybe even goes negative a little bit
when if you look further down the road
at least in our forecast by the time you
get through 2026 go in 2027 inflation is
coming back to the Target
so
would the bank of England take interest
rates to zero or even set them at
negative levels simply because the
inflation rate in the middle of 2025 is
zero or mildly negative
if they look through all that and say
well it's going to come back to two
percent let's not over stimulate the
economy right now then I think one can
make a bit more sense of the market
expectations for bank rate and our own
forecast for inflation
thank you very much
thank you very much and we've got the
oecd and the IMF we've invited them both
and hopefully we can get them timetabled
so that we can ask them are their side
of the story yeah thank you great
questions John
uh can I stay with inflation but bring
it to Bear the subject on our debt debt
um interest payments and spending if you
like
um we know that overall debt interest
spending is going to double
um this year compared to last
but we also know that index linked dead
if you like has quadrupled in the last
so 20 years as a percentage of GDP
Rising for something like six percent to
22 of GDP some inflation has is much
more relevant to how much we obviously
spend on our debt interest payments
now you'll have to excuse a slight I'm
going to be slight provocative here but
some of us are are skeptical or forecast
when it comes to inflation
um you know for long periods when it was
clear that courtesy of quantitative
easing
um artificially low interest rates that
inflation was in pockets of the economy
that we had high monetary growth and yet
still the policy makers not just here
but globally we're saying inflation is
not a problem then when it was evident
it was going to be a problem it was
going to be transitory
but it was evident it wasn't going to be
transitory it was going to fall away
this year I mean there's a pattern
developing here which doesn't Inspire
confidence I mean you have inflation
falling into negative territory from
2024. I mean I put it to you that you
know that's for the birds isn't it
um well we'll see
um I mean I I hope we're right because
actually it would if if it turned out to
be right it would be very helpful to
households because the the reason it
might turn out to be right is that the
market expectations of oil and gas
prices itself turns out to be a
reasonable guide
now that may be wrong
um we use it as a central forecast but
the uncertainty about around that is
obviously enormous
um if one went back to
the middle of
2021 and asked what was the market
forecast for where gas prices would be
today
I can't remember exactly but it was
probably about 60 Pence for third when
they're three pounds whatever they are
so there's there's 600 there's six times
higher than yeah if I come in there I
mean inflation was Rising before Oh the
Russian invasion that is true no
absolutely and monetary growth was going
through the roof and still policy makers
not just in this country has to be said
this is suggesting that inflation is not
going to be a problem now we'll see what
happens when the engine prices fall out
but it's because it's a much bigger
problem that policy makers originally
forecast and they have now playing
catch-up yeah having been behind the
curve I I have some I have a good
disability with what you say because I
think there was a tendency during the
course of uh 2021
to stimulate demands through monetary
policy
perhaps paying less attention than than
in retrospect should have been paid to
the diminished Supply potential of the
economies and bottlenecks and here in
the UK a labor force that was actually
smaller than we thought so you ran up
against if you like demand pushing up
against the supply capacity of the
economy and that has nothing to do with
Ukraine and
I agree with that but I think I think
the reason the reason why we have had
such a spike in inflation
which otherwise may may well have gone
above the target levels of central banks
which has been above for quite a while
which which absolutely which it was
before
the energy pricing but I think what was
added to that was something which was
much more powerful which was just this
enormous increase which then took
inflation into double digit figures can
I because I'm conscious that we've still
got a little way to go
um Etc with other members wishing to
speak but can I just press you a little
bit on this forecast that inflation is
going to fall into negative territory
from 2024 to what extent do you step
back from the minutiae detail and look
at medium term drivers of inflation I
put to you that you know business supply
chains are being shortened as we speak
partly because of geopolitical tensions
are hardening but also because of the
pandemic that is going to be
inflationary we've got climate change
increasingly disrupting weather and
causing food shortages and other things
we've got aging demographics which means
it's going to be compound the labor
shortages we've got the existence of
zombie companies courtesy of these
extremely low interest rate
policy that took all governments or most
governments have employed which is
represented or resulted in a
misallocation of capital there's no more
creative or very reduce creative
destruction to make sure that the
capital is allocated to more productive
means
and when inflation gets embedded it
stays there it's very difficult to shift
it enters the human psyche now those
medium-term drivers which I accept are
difficult to forecast and put on a data
set or a computer because how do you
forecast human behavior
hmm suggest that inflation is going to
remain elevated and volatile for some
time to come I mean I think you're right
if in the sense that if if expectations
of inflation really get baked
into people's psyche
and people if they can push for seven
eight nine percent wage settlements
as far ahead as one could look it is
very very unlikely that inflation will
drop into negative what about those
other medium-term drivers if you don't
mind me asking well I think those
medium-term drivers do with with
demographics and Supply chains
absolutely affect the supply potential
of the UK economy and our our forecast
reflects some of that because we think
the supply potential of the UK economy
by the time you get to 2027 it's three
and a half percent less than we thought
in um in March so we we have invaded in
our forecast
a big hit to the supply potential of the
UK economy but what we also get in the
short run are two things what one a
really sharp slow down in the near term
which creates quite a lot of slack in
the economy unemployment goes up
demands fall short of even a diminished
Supply capacity can I just very finely
can I just ask then why do you think
policy makers
just here as I say this is a global time
I've got it so wrong about inflation in
the past
um
so you can just slightly repeating
myself but I I think it looks such a
catastrophic error it looks that way
as opposed to
a smaller era that was nonetheless
significant it looks sort of
catastrophic when you have a central
bank with a Target two percent inflation
the inflation rate is 11 and would have
been potentially 13 and a half percent
were it not for government support in
the form of the energy price guarantee
that looks catastrophic
I think a significant part of the
catastrophe there really is global
things that no one could easily have
predicted and they're coming from the
Russian invasion of the Ukraine and
what's happened to Gas Energy basis so I
think I think one has to strip that bit
out because in a sense it's a forgivable
error even though they were ignoring
monetary growth figures evidence well I
I agree that deflation in widespread
parts that aspect of not having
tightened policy or in fact Lucent
policy on such a scale during 2021 I
think could legitimately described as a
policy error it's perhaps easier you
know I describe it that way it's easy
for me to say that in retrospect
um I I think you perhaps saw in ahead of
many people listening to what you're
saying
um
and that's that's a a policy mistake but
I think it exaggerates it a bit when one
looks at just the headline numbers for
inflation now and in in into the next 12
months because on top of that was the
thing that you could be I think forgiven
for not forecasting
thank you
um the 0.4 billion for interest uh this
year so nearly five percent of GDP a lot
of that's to do with the index link
structure how much is it cash accrual
and how much is a an actual rolling up
in terms of the index link principle so
but it's it's certainly the case that
the
Spike if you see interest costs this
year is partly cash interest going up on
normal fuels but another large effect of
that is the fact that all of the
all the the impact their Cruise of
indexing Tech yeah gets scored in one
year yeah indeed and do we know how much
that is what's the breakdown well so the
total spending
the two billion and the almost all of
that will be the accrual reflecting the
fact that the value of the debt has gone
up it's a very tiny amount it won't be
in the financing requirement of the debt
management office okay thanks very much
Siobhan
issues about personal income tax
your economic forecast states that by
2024-25 the tax burden will be its
highest level since the second world war
what impact was such a high tax burden
have on economic growth
um so
I think that the economic evidence
across countries and and historically at
the kind of tax burden we're talking
about in the UK in this forecast is that
there's not a tight link between how
economies grow and and how high the tax
burden is
essentially because these are relatively
moderate tax burdens so and the tax
rates that are charged are relatively
moderate we're not there are no 80 tax
rates left
um so if you look across say Europe you
can find countries with higher tax
burdens than the UK that grow faster and
you can find ones with lower tax burdens
that grow faster so we look at we don't
look at the tax burden as a way to
forecast growth we look at individual
tax measures
um so in in this forecast we've got
several measures that raise personal
income taxes
and
and within the forecast there are things
that were announced previously in
particular the threshold freezes
throughout personal taxation which are
I'm careful not to say they're raising a
lot of Revenue because essentially we
have negative real income growth at the
moment so what those threshold freezes
do is reduce the extent to which revenue
is lost
through real incomes falling
um but relative to where the threshold
would have been if raised with inflation
they raise you know 25 to 30 billion
depending on which measures you by the
end of the forecast and I'll probably
ask David to go through the detail but
we do we assume that that has a moderate
negative impact you'll anticipating my
next question
well I'll probably stop there and let
David take over on like how we think
about what that does to the choices that
people make in the labor market
um
some of them obviously because the value
of allowances will be eroded and there
are more people who face High tax rates
and their marginal tax rates are higher
and our assessment is that on balance
that will that's a disincentive to work
it's a disincentive because we think
that
there are two offsetting effects one
which is slightly more powerful
so you get less
pay to keep as a result of working the
extra hour or the extra day in the week
uh that's a disinformation on the other
hand but also also um
insane promotion I'm just thinking about
in the public sector in particular
becoming a police Sergeant or or
becoming a deputy head or a head of year
yeah
you're right the distance engine effect
is clear enough from from higher taxes
there's an old setting of here which
goes slightly in the other direction
which is that
higher average rates of tax and for many
people the average rate of tax they'll
pay on their income is going to be that
much higher to the extent that it
reduces their disposable income if they
if they try and compensate for that
um they might well work a little a
little bit more so you've got economics
job and you've got a substitution effect
which is a disincentive to work and
you've got an income effect which is
because you're in your art tax income is
lower you might actually work a bit a
bit harder
our judgment is that the the
distortionary negative effect of higher
taxes is stronger of those two so you do
you do get a negative effect on the
supply potential of the economy from
labor Supply being lower than it
otherwise
would
uh and things like freezing the tax
allowances over time will will do that
so that's a negative
um of course we've also uh had the
decision not to implement their Health
and Social care Levy so that's a
reduction in intact
that that is an offset to that the net
effect of all this we think is
um a a small but nonetheless non-trivial
uh slight reduction in the Labor's play
in the UK
um
I agree very much with what uh Andy was
saying which is that within limits the
tax take out a GDP can go up or down a
few percentage points and it probably
doesn't have an enormous negative or
positive effect on the supply potential
of the economy
but one can't push that argument too far
because there does come a point and it
may be that we're not so close to that
point yet in the UK and it does come a
point where the distortionary effects
just get greater and greater and they're
they're likely to be what you might call
non-linear
um so whilst I agree
that the distortionary effects of the
kind of higher overall tax take out of
GDP we might see in the UK might not do
what you might call material damage to
the supply potential of the economy
the idea that you could just keep doing
things like that without doing damage to
the supply potential economy is clearly
not true
um
it's notable that that I thought the
Autumn statement was notable for its
absence of the words nondon
research from the lse indicates that
clamping down on non-doms would raise
around 3.2 billion pounds is this a
figure that you recognize
um we we don't work on our comment on
policies that the government's not asked
us to work on so I'm afraid that's a
good question for somebody else uh
we haven't explored
at all okay and probably and you're not
going to want to answer my next question
either
um the government uh stubbornness is
resulting in tax-free incomes for the
millionaires while Millions face uh
Frozen tax allowances and council tax
hikes uh some say 3.2 billion is a drop
in the ocean do you agree with me that
when it comes to public finances that's
rather a large drop that doesn't kind of
State Market comment
okay those are my questions
a very important part and how you adjust
it to the overall economic growth
yesterday we had a group of economists
in
and
their overall comment was that while a
lot has been done to address the tax and
spend issues that in terms of meat about
growth
um it was it was a bit thin as in levers
to actually deliver that growth
therefore it becomes increasingly
important to make sure that the tax
measures are rights proportionate and
will deliver what's expected so they
don't dampen growth
when you look at the increase in the
personal uh taxes and the business taxes
which do you think has the biggest
impact on growth and therefore we should
be most concerned about on the growth
agenda
um
significant changes to tax policy in in
this Autumn statement and in the run-up
to it considered even bigger ones
um in the end they've had sort of
broadly offsetting effects because
you've had a big reduction in personal
taxation that we've had we haven't gone
ahead with the Health and Social Care
Living but then you've frozen the
thresholds we think that the net effect
of that is is uh smaller than the effect
that any one of those measures would
have had but but mildly negative for
labor Supply you've got ahead with the
corporation tax rise
which which has an effect on post-tax
incentives uh to invest
um and but overall the confidence if you
look at the how you've written up the
policy measures in the book and the way
of analyzed them in the forecast there's
really been not very much long-term
growth effect from any of the from the
net effect of all the policy measures
taken in this Autumn statement and there
are other factors which have led us to
slightly change our view of long-run
potential outputs in the UK but none of
it really derives from the policy
measures taken in this in this budget
there are some actions like this like
like the ones we had on the public
investment side which in the longer term
could have an impact on Supply potential
but I think to be to be frank what's
notable about
this forecast and policy terms is that
very few of them have fed through into
our assessment and long term
and that will be true provided that the
estimate particularly for something like
corporation tax because that's a big
earner are right
um so I was a bit surprised I have to
understand given what you said that you
think it will lower output by only
0.2 and when I look at the figures uh
the the billion expected tax receipts
over the years
in uh 2374 we're looking at
88.8 billion in 2728 we're going to
105.4 billion
those are big numbers which
seemed to me to raise a question mark
how
certain are you what's your level of
certainty and perhaps before you answer
that let me just refer back to something
which a professor Miles said earlier and
that was his assumption that the energy
prices would come down and therefore
that was the justification and I think
my concern about that comment is that
while wholesale prices have absolutely
come down then how low and they were
pre-pandemic the challenge we have is
that
the the output spend by the businesses
and the individuals is the retail price
not the wholesale price
and a number of individuals partly
through Fear Factor partly because
they're incentivized to do so because
that meant that they could then benefit
from the government schemes entered into
sometimes quite long fixed some
contracts at the highest rate sometimes
their periods as long as five years does
that not give you pause for thought that
your assumption and then feeding that
energy prices coming down uh is is going
to make this all right on the night is
perhaps uh a little optimistic so on
your first question and David will want
to comment on the overall the underlying
optimism with the forecast as a whole
but on your first point about how
uncertain are we about the corporation
tax forecast if the answer is it's among
one of those uncertain aspects of our
forecast always
um and in particular this time in the
corporation taxes levied on profits it
depends on the profitability of
businesses it's it's by its very nature
and there are lots of
so it is by its very nature much more
volatile than income tax which so long
as people have a job um and they're
getting paid they pay uh this time
around there are some big tax changes
some big changes in rates um which could
have could have you know larger larger
behavioral effects than you might expect
from smaller changes as well as
um some quite normal things going on the
sort of pillar 2 reforms
um which Levy uh minimum level of uh so
try to collect minimum amount of
cooperation tax from companies uh
residents in your in operating in your
in in particular jurisdictions raise
huge huge uncertainty about are these
things going to be able to be
implemented and then once they are
implemented
um how how successful are they in a
given period so in in that sense our our
corporation tax forecast is always very
uncertain that there are sort of
additional reasons to be uncertain
um this time around on the sort of wider
question of the answer the underlying
I'll sort of holy government forecast
and the business investment part of it
Dave wants to add more time I think
there are lots of sources of uncertainty
in the forecast
um and you've highlighted ones I think
is one of the big ones which is what
happens to wholesale Energy prices and
does it get s pass through to hostels
and and companies
um
our Central assumption
is
that the market forward curves for the
energy prices tell you something about
the most likely part
um
but the price could be dramatically
different from what the markets are
expecting right now and if they are it
will make a very big difference the
forecast and it could be the difference
between inflation you know zero or
slightly negative in 2025 and inflation
being you know four five six percent
um so which will have a huge impact on
households and disposable income and all
that on the issue of some people of
haged and used Futures contracts and
they fixed prices that's absolutely
right
our assumption is that as you go further
into the future those kind of Hedges
roll off and ultimately the underlying
wholesale price is what drives the cost
to to people but you're right it affects
the Dynamics of when they start paying
for things that's true okay because my
concern is you were talking about this
falling in uh 24 25 if you're a
five-year contract yes then then when
we're making a difference you're
absolutely right
um the point at which our forecast
actually gets inflation done
slightly negative territory it's it's a
little ways down the road it's it's sort
of toward the middle and back only 25
going into 2026.
it's on 100 goods are to be removed
so do you think that will shift uh your
growth expectations how much difference
will it make and what goods do you
anticipate are going to be impacted by
this
so that's probably wrong for me
um the I mean this has not affected our
growth forecast basically because the
um the measures themselves they cost
around 115 million pounds so that's you
know very small
economy I'm I'm not I'm afraid I'm not
sure if all the goods are in the public
domain but you know these are Goods that
businesses have requested to be zero
tariff
the cost uh reflects how much of them is
imported so it's very important for
those involved but macro macro
economically quite small all right I I I
accept that and I can only assume
therefore it's more to do with uh if
you're like emotional cultural
um feel good Factor rather than
necessarily purely
Financial which might change Behavior
otherwise your right is very much more
better r d very important and indeed the
chancellor said it was very important
and said that was something that he
wanted to ensure we retained and yet
the chancellor cut only tax credits for
small businesses
what's the impact of that going to be
because the FSB as you know are
absolutely aghast and in full flood and
cry about it
so again in in the forecast we've
assumed that in terms of what it means
for the volume of r d spending
that the gains from making the large
company scheme more generous
offset the what you lose from making a
small company scheme less generous and
so we've left our business investment
forecast unchanged because the
composition changes but the total
doesn't Okay
um now the r d tax credits it's one area
of tax policy where the evidence on its
growth impact is quite strong but the
other thing that has become in
increasingly apparent in recent years is
that the small company scheme was being
abused as well as being used properly
and so we do assume that some of what
happens as a result of making the small
companies scheme their standard
systems or less money is lost that way
so that's why the the combination of the
two measures
raises money
um but in what we kind of think of as
the
appropriate use of the two schemes the
rebalancing really is a balance to
rebalance it all
okay
I'll move on to investment zones but it
seems to me from what you're saying is
proportionally the smaller businesses
are being
penalized to deal with a full problem
whereas in fact perhaps isn't the right
way push it you're not going to comment
on policy but that was a very
interesting comment thank you so the
investment zones have been moved so
effectively instead of being part of
leveling up they're now part of
um potential or high clusters uh
fats would achieve a very different
objective to the objective that was
initially sat clearly it's a policy
issue not for you but in terms of if you
like the impact on economic growth was
this will that achieve it and what do
you see
as the targets
hypertensional cluster are we talking
University are we talking uh high-tech
areas
um I I think it's too soon to say I mean
my my reading of what's in the Autumn
statement document is that the
government's in a kind of talking to
stakeholders figuring out what the best
approach is Phase
um there have been similar policies over
the past decade that we have looked at
so the Enterprise zones that came with
business
and the free ports that are getting
underway
um neither of those have we moved our
growth forecast for them and the thing
we tend to worry about when we look at
look at the growth perspective is
whether essentially whether they're
Regional policy that moves activity
around the country or whether they are
growth policy that increases the size of
the pie and I think with the Enterprise
zones the evidence was you know very
largely that they moved activity around
um with the free ports policy I think
the treasury was quite careful in how it
put together the prospectus and
try to avoid that
now we've basically taken a kind of wait
and see approach on that if if they are
successful then it will show up in
growth but we haven't anticipated that
so this will be I think in the kind of
in the same camp when the details come
forward
thank you thank you thank you thank you
very much indeed Alison thank you very
much I've got some further questions
around energy support packages and I
just wanted to ask first of all how in
total costs of the new energy support
package it Compares with the one
initially announced in September
um
so
the as announced in September it would
have been so just looking at the energy
price guarantee for for Simplicity so it
would have cost uh 25 billion this year
which uh
is the cost of the scheme as it's going
ahead about 27 billion yeah
Nestor
cap to 3 000 pounds the cost is more
like 13 million
stopping it after after next winter
rather than extending it through next
the following summer that saves another
about 4 billion
okay it's quite a significant difference
between the two there and in your
section on the various economic and
physical risks within the year before we
noticed that you know the various Cliff
edges regarding energy related support
can you tell me a bit more about the
kind of risks of those Cliff edges and
what that I will mean for for people in
the real economy
so um you know when we're talking about
Cliff edges we're you know we're just
talking about the schemes ending that uh
or changing at different points
um you know we're making I think a
relatively simple Point
um that you know what you saw through
the pandemic with the furlough scheme
was that there were several end dates
and
um the chancellor looked at them each
time
um relative to what was happening in the
pandemic and decided to extend it a
number of times so the rise to 3 000
pounds in April is during the recession
in our forecast in the obviously the
ending
will be you know depending on what
energy prices are you know could have
very little effect I
the wholesale Energy prices at the
moment if they if they're approved right
which obviously we've discussed as
very uncertain then the when the off-gem
price cap comes back into play Energy
prices will basically smoothly move
higher than there's a potential for
another step up there
yeah so there's a huge gap really
between what could happen in various
different scenarios and that will have a
significant impact on what the
what figures the Transformers to play
with then
yes and obviously they'd have big
impacts on everything else if Energy
prices were higher for long
ER tax revenue because so this is a very
direct and kind of visible impact but it
would
everything yeah but quite significant
uncertainty Within These predict Within
These forecasts absolutely as you
as you pick and shock
okay how much would reduce the
government's Bill if it passed on and
some of those additional costs and the
uncertainty to households by raising the
energy price guarantee again
uh Beyond its current end right as I say
if if wholesale gas price
the Futures Market is a good Guide to
the Future then
um wholesale prices suggest that
the off-gen price count will be around
about 3 000 pounds in uh early 2024 and
declining
um quite steadily so in our Central
forecast you know there's nothing more
to change
if you extended the cap at a higher rate
it wouldn't bind
but obviously there's huge uncertainty
around that yeah you know what that's
for you have you done any modeling on
the effect that government support
schemes will have on energy consumption
within you know how people respond to
these types of schemes and what they
will do
uh yeah the forecasts um embodies um
work that I think it was that the
government did a few years ago that um
suggests it puts
elasticity so the the response of energy
consumption to higher prices uh I'm
gonna I think the number is 0.1 so 0.1
is a you know for every 10 the price
Rises um
one percent that's a small response
because energy is obviously an essential
in other markets it will be much higher
so the the forecast has embody that I
mean I think what we've seen in some of
the
um you know there isn't kind of hard
data on this yet but some of the people
monitoring what they can about energy
usage energy usage in October the first
month of EPG was down a lot of course it
was a unseasonably warm month so I'm not
sure what we can draw for that
okay
and
there's been quite a significant bit of
chat about the the impact of and
increasing the whole insulation money
and the government has proposed a lot of
that won't kick in for a while so it's
maybe outside your kind of forecast area
but would you have any kind of impact of
what how much uh installation would have
to be put in to see a significant impact
in memory usage I'm afraid I don't know
around the impact on business now
businesses in my constituency have shown
me some of the eye watering bills that
they're being asked to sign up right now
I mean it's really quite unaffordable
but there is no other contract on offer
and for them for some of those
businesses they're looking at that in
terms of well the only way I can see if
any money is cut in production
I can't see if I'm Staffing I can't save
it on the coast of the building I can't
you know there's no possibility of
saving anything on these bills because
that's the cheapest I can afford what
impact does that have more widely in the
economy if there isn't support for some
of these businesses come in the spring
um well
So within our forecast the the support
for businesses is assumed to end in the
spring I know the government are
reviewing it for what will
afterwards and that is one of the that's
one of the factors in it pushes up
inflation for those businesses that can
pass it on and it affects economic
activity it's one of the reasons why by
David has more to say on that and not
just the recession and even though we
think the best guess and it's not much
more than a guess is that energy prices
drop back there's still drop back to
levels that are way higher than they
were just a couple of years ago
and because of that we think that
there's there's a hit that a permanent
hit as long as Energy prices stay there
that's the productive capacity of the
economy so I said a while back that by
the end of the forecast we think the
productive potential UK economy is three
and a half percent lower than it
otherwise would be and a big chunk of
that is to do with Energy prices just
being permanently higher than we used to
think was was normal
it's a long run effect not just a sort
of shore manager
and is there any particular impact so
thinking of some of the businesses I
that I've been speaking to in a whole
range of different large and small
Charities as well they've got these
baked in
additional costs
is there a kind of point at which
European companies can't afford that
anymore and you see a wave you know
there's already I think an increasing
rate of insolvencies some companies have
built up a lot of covert debt and they
really don't have anywhere else to go
with this additional cost
and is there a point in which there
becomes a Tipping Point for the economy
there as well where you're seeing prices
that businesses can't afford and then a
subsequent running to further
unemployment because that you've talked
about unemployment going up at some
stage as well
I mean I think that's right but um you
know it's tipping points for individual
businesses and then as that accrues that
you know it looks smooth
um in our forecast for GDP but that's
because that's the total for the total
is um
is a combination of those for whom
the end of that business
and those who can pass the costs on and
those who complain it in the way so
um
so I don't think there's like a Tipping
Point where the economy goes into Free
Fall it's just you know
prices remain higher and higher
and more and more activity is is
unprofitable and then that's the effect
that David was talking about like the
long term
that the product
key input production is more expensive
and it's a particular challenge for
manufacturing because they just tend to
be much more energy intensive better
than service Industries although some
Services just have big premises which
you have to heat in light and so they
have energy bills which are a big share
of their costs but it is one of the
reasons why you refer to the recently
report earlier
um they have a fairly sort of
idiosyncratic set of countries
um in terms of their growth Outlook in
the coming years in this another country
which is also suffering particularly
over the next year is Germany and that
is for a slightly different reason in
the UK Germany has a very big
manufacturing sector they're paying much
higher production costs in the uh in the
UK we rely a lot on gas for household
Heating and household electricity and
businesses do to something secondary
manufacturing
um but for the UK it's it's uh high gas
prices put pressure on households on
consumption and on inflation that way
for countries like Germany with large
manufacturing sectors it puts pressure
on on production because it's a big
input into production but there are
parts of the UK where we have big
manufacturing sectors
um and they're they're an important
employer and they're important part of
the local economy and that can happen up
on effects on the rest of you
we've done any a model air forecasting
about the cost of extending the current
energy support for businesses and what
that could look like
again because we're required to forecast
on the basis of current
important I'm just curious as it sounded
from the chancellor as if there would be
some announcement between now and next
uh next April and I just wondered where
that's going to follow this idea
forecasting here but before you come
back to us with another forecast so just
wondering if there's any opportunity to
take that and deck out in a separate
report perhaps
um that would have to depend on them
when the treasury is reviewing it I
think is
falling out with
I mean in terms of that you would expect
it to be captured in the budget yeah and
finally I just wanted to ask very
quickly um about your assumptions around
immigration within the report and if
there's anything more you could tell me
about the basis on which you're making
those assumptions sure
um so uh for a long time well since that
um since the the referendum we've
assumed we revised down our assumption
about the long run steady state level of
migration in the UK at the time around
the time of the referendum in
anticipation of the fact that
um our decision to leave the EU and also
the entire ability to set our own
migration regime would in the long run
have an effect on net migration into the
UK it had been running at sort of over
200 000 for the years running after the
referendum we assume that
um the government's post brexit
migration regime which was announced
implemented in 2020 would reduce
sort of average levels of migration down
to something closer to the to 100 to
just over a hundred thousand 129 000. as
it's turned out
um and as we've observed the new system
in operation uh when it came in in early
2000s uh net migration levels have
stayed in above 200 000 the the last
number uh we had to the year to June of
this year was 239 000. and so in light
of that it looks as though the
government's new migration regime is
basically just allowing in more people
than we could anticipated
um and so on that basis we've revised up
our assumption for the long run steady
state level of migration from 129 000 to
205 000 and at the moment it's it's a
bit above that at around 239 so it's
sort of
um it it it falls slightly down to that
higher that higher figure than we had as
the basis for for net migration in our
previous design okay that's interesting
you probably won't want to comment on
this but there's some rumor that said
the Home Secretary had resigned in part
about the forecast around immigration
within a a the sort of economic
assumptions but it's not something
either
thanks Alison and Danny I think you have
one quick question on this topic didn't
you if that and then I'll bring in
Andrea okay that's actually I I just
want to push you a bit a bit harder if
you don't mind on this question of
energy uh costs falling because I'm not
I I think it feels like we're sort of
betting the farm on this assumption I
mean the whole basis of the forecast
that you made
um which is in a sense propping up the
government's awesome statement is on the
Assumption of very radical cores in
energy costs over the next year and when
we're asking you why you assume that's
to happen you say well that's what the
market is predicting I mean that's what
markets do they make predictions they
make bets
I mean it is that really it or can you
give us your own assessment of why you
think Energy prices are going to fall
actually to you know there'll be
negative information in energy next year
what is the reason for that are you
literally is it assuming the war's going
to end is that it or is that what was
there some massive increase in Supply
what is it so we do so we do rely on on
the Futures curves as a as as the guide
for what energy price to use in our
forecast and I should say it's a it's a
convention used by most other MacBook 9
forecasters the bank of England do the
same we we are at pains to do
sensitivity analysis and risk analysis
around those numbers to explore the
implications of different scenarios
actually back in July we produced a
whole chapter of our fiscal risks report
looking at the risks around the Outlook
the energy prices including the
scenarios where prices came back came
back more quickly and stayed low as well
as scenarios where prices stayed high
without getting inside the mind of
people in the markets you don't quite
know what they're thinking about where
Engine prices are going to go but but
you're right it does it does it does
assume that at some point in the coming
uh two to three years Supply pressures
on Europe ease through a combination of
finding alternative sources of gas LNG
in particular which has been rising
potentially it into the war in Ukraine
but that is anyone's guess not something
that we're we have any expertise in
forecasting and and for that reason
um don't even try and then also there's
an element of demand destruction which
is that people find people shift away
from energy energy lower the energy
intensity in general of either the
household or their business or their
fine alternative sources of energy from
gas as a way of bringing down the
overall cost of energy
um to the country as a whole and we
assume there's some combination of those
things does bring down gas prices and
that appears to be well also markets are
using um but you're absolutely right
um a huge amount depends on that you
know that coming to pass we do explore
scenarios where gas prices are higher
um and we are we are at pain to try and
emphasize we'll be making these kind of
judgments and our forecasting conditions
on them what the risks around those are
another 70 billion pounds or the energy
price guarantee is if the uh the energy
prices
and also a lower lower potential output
for the UK as a country
there is another way of looking at this
which is which is the the wholesale
prices stabilize at a level that is
three or four times what was normal
uh the world does not have less gas it's
that it's being disrupted by geopolitics
so
one could look at this and say why
doesn't it fall all the way back to
where it was and maybe that is because
the market doesn't think the war is
going to end
something else
um the other when we were looking at
Energy prices in in the summer like some
of the pushback we had from the experts
we were talking to is that assuming
fossil fuel prices remain high forever
is just inconsistent with if you believe
the world is going to be able to wean
itself off fossil fuels and move to
Renewables because the demand for them
will fall
so yeah uncertainty is huge but I think
it does go in both directions
thanks very much Daniel I'm going to
bring in Andrew yes thank you pleasure
to see you and my sincere apologies for
leaving for a chunk it was a
pre-existing commitment to a school so I
couldn't just let them down so do say if
someone's already asked you that
question and I'll try to avoid asking um
something that Strays but I did want to
just start off by uh I think Danny's
made the point very well at the inherent
difficulty with forecasting and and
inevitably the one thing you can be sure
of with forecasting is it will always be
wrong because you'll never get it spot
on have you ever got a forecast
absolutely spot on no I like like
weather forecasters you know we try and
we try and prevent things yeah within
within error bands yeah like weather
forecasters we don't predict the precise
temperature on a given day or the
precise rainfall so we never plan our
picnics around the weather forecast but
we do certainly plan our public
expenditure around the obr forecasting
and with that in mind I just wonder and
I I'm not trying to be difficult here
but you are extremely predominantly male
and from the city and from the treasury
do you think that forecasting would
benefit from having a a more diverse
range of people involved in making obr
forecasting analysis in particular
perhaps people who are very often
deciding on the household budget such as
women I I do I think forecasters
forecasting always benefits from taking
an array of perspectives and avoiding
grouping
um I I'm pleased to say in the obr we've
made a lot of progress in in terms of
the gender balance of our staff you're
right that the three of us are on our
you know our our mail um uh but if you
look at the opposition of our staff um
it is it is uh close to parity and and
has been getting closer over time
um on our on our board
um uh we have mixed agendas on our
senior leadership team we do as well uh
but you know we really do you've got one
woman on your Advisory Board I googled
this earlier because I was amazed that
the three of you are men and you've got
one woman who does audit on your
Advisory Board oh well she provides a
lot of advice uh and input to us but
there are only five people on our board
in general but I agree there is more
work to be done in the OVR um to improve
gender diversity
um at all levels but it's not gender
diversity is it it's difference of
experience it's who runs I mean who runs
household budgets predominantly which
gender runs household budgets in in the
UK do you have the answer to that
um I'm I'm sure women play more than
their role than men in the UK as they do
around the world yeah
and that there is therefore it's it's
not just about gender diversity is it
it's about
noting the inherent difficulty with
forecasting it's about actually taking
views from across different experiences
and in the case of the obr you're not
taking the experiences of
the very often women who are running the
household budget and you are
predominantly ex treasury civil servants
and city financiers are you not I'm
afraid I would take issue with that we
do take views from a broad range of
stakeholders our staff
um as I said is is relatively balanced
in gender terms I think is also from a
range of both professional backgrounds
and ethnic backgrounds
um myself yes I worked in the treasury
for most of my career I also worked
abroad in the international monetary
fund and in other places
um and so I think we do we do our best
to both reflect diversity our staff and
our in our perspectives we talk to a
very wide range of forecasters when we
put our forecasts together
um ultimately what we need is expertise
in forecasting
um and that can be that can be hard to
find it can be especially hard to find
for the salaries that we pay in the
public sector compared to what you can
get paid in the city but we do our best
our staff are not all drawn from the
treasury by any means and they are drawn
from all sorts of different parts of the
labor force um what we want what we want
above and above and beyond all
um is objectivity and what we want as
expertise and I think we get that
um as well as providing a pretty good
representation in terms of diversity so
just one last question on that an
Advisory Board to me is
people who by
a mature of their diverse experience at
providing advice so they neither need to
be paid a massive sum nor do they need
to be expert forecasters they just need
to be people who've had different life
experiences and on that definition your
Advisory Board is not very diverse in
gender in life experience or would you
say that that's not correct well we take
advice from a lot of different sources
are not Executives or there's one man
and there's one woman
um one one has worked in the treasury
and one has not worked in the treasury
so
um and so at the extent that we have
somebody who's we benefit from advice
from somebody who's done our jobs in
different contexts at a different time
but as well as somebody who's looked at
the whole system from the outside and
judged it
um I think we do get a reasonably good
set of advice from those uh those two
people
um you know
uh in terms of those aren't the only
people we rely on for advice we look
across the becomes freshman we look
across industry when we've got
particular challenges like energy we are
we ask energy experts
um and we look to get a wider range of
views as we can because there is no
single expert on any subjects okay thank
you so I've just got a couple of
questions on the windfall taxes and the
energy profits Levy and the electricity
generator Levy
um what uh your your forecast suggests
that the energy profits Levy now with
giving a total headline tax rate of 75
of profits and that that is quite a
significant sum and obviously that is
designed through the Autumn statement to
be offsetable against investment in the
UK can you tell us how you've taken into
account the potential Behavior change
and how you forecast for Behavior change
um yeah so the I mean the energy profits
Levy uh was announced in May and amended
in the Autumn statement so this is this
is one of the
um policy measures that we're able to
take on quite a lot of external views on
when we're thinking about how companies
will respond
um in a kind of spreadsheet sense the
investment allowance and the higher tax
rate increases the incentive to invest
and so if you were looking at this
purely on those grounds you would expect
investment to rise as a result of
package
the whole
measure
but the
um I'm going to forget the name the
previously known as oil and gas UK which
changed his name recently oh I'm sure
what's it called offshore energies UK
then no no sorry though oil and gas
Authority the government links one oh
okay I'm sorry I've forgotten
but they They carried out a survey of
what people would do in response
um we were we were particularly
interested in that because our concern
was that although on paper it increases
the incentive there is just this is the
tax rate being changed and the tax
system being kind of uh changed
frequently
um and whether that would act as a
disincentive and I think based on a
combination of looking at how this
should work in theory and looking at the
responses we were seeing in practice we
thought that those effects would
basically would offset so we did not
change our forecast for the volume of
investment in the North Sea as a result
of this measure
that kind of uncertainty would often
would offset the the investment
incentive that comes through the
allowance okay so you think that
your your conclusion then is that the um
offshore energy companies will pay the
additional tax but they won't invest
that that but they won't use the
offsetable investment allowance in the
UK so they'll just pay it as tax rather
than use it to invest in net terms in
aggregate so for some some will respond
One Way some may be put off by what's
happened and so but if you're if you're
a company and you're faced with I can
just give you the money in tax or I can
spend the money on growing my business
why would you say I'll just pay the
money in tax
well for some will have investment plans
in place already and the what we've
assumed is that those investment plans
will not change in Aggregate and I'm not
saying that for individual companies
they won't move
some will have been well decide to
invest somewhere else or you know do
less because the tax rate is high and
what if it changes again
uh type of consideration so you know for
some they will be able to offset you
know all because they have large
investment plans and some people
so to the idea the assumptions we've
made are based on the assumption that
there will
effects from those discouraged and those
encouraged
okay I would have thought the rational
thing to do is to offset right up to the
level of the tax that is allowable
that would be the rational thing for a
company to do but
anyway okay and then
um in terms of if prices
unexpectedly did return to 2021 levels
do you have a view a forecast on what
that would do to tax receipts
uh we we didn't look at that sensitivity
in uh
um in the epho this time we looked at
the potential income of the potential
impact of much higher
prices given the uh what we were talking
about earlier about how exposed the
Public Finance as far that are via the
EPG
um
if you know
the we have revised up our forecast for
revenues very very substantially and so
you know the impact on revenues from
this tax and also you know more broadly
the taxes on the North Sea and
and
several billions possibly in the tens of
billions if uh prices were to collapse
yes okay six okay is that one last
question yeah thank you um yes so there
isn't a similar investment allowance for
the electricity generated generated Levy
does that mean you've costed investment
Behavior differently or have you assumed
like with the offshore energy that it's
just all Nets out
um so this one is
more complicated and I you know feel
less confident in what will happen the
the thing that we focused on most here
was that the generators Levy is
in some sense more clearly a women fall
tax so it's not just a higher rate on
all profits it is a tax rate that is
applied to revenue Beyond a certain
price and only for those generators in
the renewable sectors that are not
covered by the contract for different
schemes
now
as I understand it new investment in
maneuver able is almost always covered
by contract for difference now
those
contracts still provide the long-term
certainty that is
the energy experts we speak to deemed to
be the most important factor in new
investment in renewable generation so on
with this one the the assumption is
again that it does not affect investment
basically because investment in
non-contract for difference renewable
capacity new investment does not go into
that sector so for new investment
with the contract different scheme
that's where that applies but as I say
I feel I feel less confident about that
one uh you know it was it was a new
measure there was no um you know we
couldn't follow uh What uh you know
surveys and businesses were saying as it
was happening
okay thank you I mean we've got the
chancellor tomorrow so we may want to
try uh that sort of line of questioning
it again
um I think in terms of today's session
you know you've highlighted some of the
challenges you faced uh over the summer
and then preparing this forecast and of
course we accept that all forecasts are
wrought within uncertainty I just want
to check that there's no one who has a
burning question before we leave I see a
couple of burning questions first uh
John who has to leave at 4 30 then
Angela yeah very briefly
um earlier I shared with you certainly
my frustration and probably others about
the lack of forecasting accuracy and
being behind the curve on the inflation
issue and so forth
um to what extent you talked about going
to the market to base a lot of your
forecasts but the market has often
improved wrong
um as I think Danny was was highlighting
I mean to what extent do you do your own
research like for example the
inflationary effect of shortening or
shortened business supply lines and
demographics do you do any of that of
your research yourself we do when when
time permits and and with and with the
limited staff complement we have we do
it we do a lot of our own research and
in particular when we when you have
these kind of idiosyncratic shocks as I
said back in July we did a big report
um both on the supply chain issue and
about in general is kind of global trade
intensity shrinking and countries
becoming more self-reliant what what
that might do to productivity and growth
as well as what are the risks around
energy markets in the near term so we do
do our own research we do their own
analysis we do talk to experts who don't
fall under the traditional definition of
macroeconomist but know something about
a trend which is driving economic
developments like energy price changes
like supply chain effects so we do we do
look into those where we think that they
have macro growing relevance or where
their novel and we need to understand
okay thank you thank you Angela and then
Danny I think you had a last question
ask about the um the increasing
um tendency of the government to uh
allow council tax increases to take the
strain of particularly paying for social
care
and you say on page 34 of your report
that you've assumed that the extra
flexibility that the government have
given local authorities to raise council
tax will actually all come through that
they will raise raise by five percent do
you check to see whether this has
happened in the past and what's the
distributional effects even more all
this money to come through because it's
skewed in terms of the capacity of
councils in different areas actually to
raise relevant amounts of money in that
way my own area for example can't raise
nearly the same amounts of money that
can be raised in in areas where property
prices are much higher when this
actually happens what do you do to take
you out of the distribution of effects
as well
so on the first time we do look back
council tax in England the referendum
principles have been uh you know two
percent three percent three percent plus
adult social care precept for uh some
years now and the out turn uh is
typically like very very very slightly
below the maximum
and so that's what we've assumed again
here
um we don't look a lot at the
distribution of how the revenue comes in
and the expenditure needs it's it's not
something we focus on for that
our job of forecasting the overall
public finances
simply that when that happens some areas
cannot use money they can't raise
because they're in a different position
and other more affluent areas with more
affluent property prices
and therefore there are skewing effects
of the way in which that money can
actually be used to deal with
um the need that there is locally on
them that over time they're getting
greater and greater but you don't pick
any of that up
I think this is one of those issues that
you know is clearly very important but
it's not uh core to our job of um
forecasting of real public finances yeah
we've got the chance
so um and then I think the last question
goes to Danny yeah very much appreciate
uh your patience and time um on page 19
of your outlook you talk about mortgage
rates and the effect on
um real household disposable income
I'm just concerned that your
you you made the point that impacts of
higher interest rates on mortgages will
be offset by increases in Saving rates
even though you think the savings could
have decline I think
um
with the implication that this is a net
neutral effect but I mean you also do
acknowledge that the changes will be
unevenly distributed which indeed you
would expect we're talking about people
with mortgages
haven't play higher mortgages other
people with savings benefiting so there
might be some net neutral effect in
theory but in practice we've got people
with very high mortgage rates to pay do
are you not concerned about the risk of
a mortgage crisis given
Rising rates
absolutely right it's it's very uh it's
very unequal and you know most of the
the savings are disproportionately owned
by people who've got higher incomes
probably probably older lower mortgages
relative to their resources and
younger people will have very little
savings they might have a large mortgage
relative to their income
and we do in fact that some of the
implications of that for consumption by
essentially assuming that the negative
hit to people who've got a big mortgage
has a bigger downward effect on their
consumption than the positive effect on
somebody who's got who's got the savings
um
is there the potential for real problems
in the housing market and large numbers
of people following me out with a
mortgage
I'm afraid that potential obviously is
there and there is certainly a risk
about that
we we use
um
the swap rates to try and work out where
the average interest rate is going to go
on the stock of mortgages it goes up for
a while
uh it's slow though because as you'll
know the
um predominantly mortgages in the UK now
become fixed rate mortgages so it
doesn't feed through to most people's
mortgage higher interest until they
remortgage so it's kind of a slow and
gradual increase in the average interest
rate on mortgage store but for any
individual household it's a big shot
probably at the time in which they their
fixed rate deal
Runs Out
the bank of England and the financial
services financial conduct Authority I
should say
um have had rules in now which I'm sure
you're very well aware of for some years
now which say that mortgage lenders have
to assess whether or not when they make
a new mortgage loan people could live
with a sudden three percent increase in
the mortgage rate and those rules have
been there for um well several years now
I mean at least seven or eight years
with my recollection so the majority of
large mortgages relative to people's
income should have been taken out in the
last seven or so years in principle the
mortgage lenders have had to assess
whether people could live with a sudden
three percent increase in interest rates
that sudden 10 increase in interest
rates on the mortgage is coming for a
very large proportion of people
one hopes that the banks in the building
societies had taken pretty seriously
what was the new rules of the game and
judge whether people could live with a
three percent increase
is there a risk that large numbers of
people can't yes I think there is a risk
the assumptions that you've made and
you've acknowledged yourselves that you
know how hard it is to forecast
particularly in these very fast changing
circumstances I think I noted one
potential follow-up which is if you've
got any more information on the Northern
Powerhouse rail situation
but other than that I think that is the
end of the session and so order order I
declare that the treasury committee
session is now over thank you it has
ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the procedure